we have now won that avada caucus a
resounding victory for Bernie Sanders as
he sealed his position as frontrunner
and moved a step closer to winning the
Democratic nomination we have just put
together a multi-generational
multiracial coalition which is gonna not
only win in Nevada
it's gonna sweep this country the
Vermont senator set up a strong and
sophisticated organization in Nevada
winning strong support from white and
Latino voters with his calls for
universal health care student debt
forgiveness and a green new deal to
defeat global warming the victory came
through the efforts of a small army of
enthusiastic mostly young volunteers
many of them gathered in downtown Las
Vegas to celebrate as the results came
in
Sanders was so confident of victory here
in Nevada that he skipped this party and
spent the day instead holding rallies in
Texas now that's one of the big
delegate-rich states that holds its
primary on Super Tuesday March 3rd
Sanders now has a boost of momentum
going into Super Tuesday Joe Biden came
in second in Nevada and is hoping to do
better in South Carolina next week
losing centrist candidates like Pete
Budaj
warned Sanders is too left-wing to
defeat President Donald Trump in
November senator Sanders believes in an
inflexible ideological revolution that
leaves out most Democrats not to mention
most Americans earlier Nevada Democratic
voters gathered in schools libraries and
casinos to stand for their candidates at
Sierra Vista High School outside Las
Vegas caucus goers argued sometimes
passionately to win over other voters
but in the end the night and Nevada
belonged to Bernie Sanders
Rob Reynolds al-jazeera Las Vegas